est-ce que vous avez 4 et une question
quelconque homme posé là dessus je dois
lui ajouter un peu de alors oui la
mayonnaise
[Musique]
la personne ne leur dit raymond assez ce
qu'ils veulent avec une énième fois
exactement ce qu'ils veulent trop vous
aviez vous n'en avez pas tant que ça
n'est ce pas mais il a fait signe que
non il est mauvaise foi non non non du
coup je prends un petit peu de sel jeux
salle très légèrement très dignement
casse tous les trucs du cerf du seul ou
deux grosses pinces et hook à petit pas
mais pour pleut la sécurité du foire par
trop pour nous avec eux j'ai un
particulièrement et que je vous je
conseillerais d'ailleurs aux
téléspectateurs en jeu met du sel n'est
ce pas voyez vous pas trop adulte on
obtenait jouer alors
[Musique]